yo D what up yo what's up man you ever
seen a female quarterback in Hawaii
starting quarterback for that high
school in Honolulu right see legit as
you got a cannon I'm gonna sing you this
details and let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
high school football in Hawaii sounds
nuts but for Alexandria Buchanan it's
not just another day in paradise last
season she earned the title of only
female starting varsity QB in Hawaii no
wonder she went viral she breaks her
team's four-year losing streak and now
she's fighting for her job
[Music]
football is a male dominant sport
everybody knows that she's um fought for
everything that she's earned nothing's
been given to her people always say like
especially in comments on articles or
whatever like people aren't gonna hit
her they're gonna look like the bad guy
cuz it's a girl like they're just gonna
let her go or in the stands people are
saying things like get her out or get
the other guy in or why is she starting
football is a contact sport I'm
expecting to get hit I'm not in flag
football anymore
[Music]
you can't say that just because I'm a
girl people will take it lightly and
it's just frustrating because I get hit
a lot and I can take it
[Music]
throwing has always been fun for me
that's what I've really enjoyed doing
nice but it's hard for people to
understand like a girl taking that
position I know I work hard and football
is something I'm really passionate about
[Music]
you have to remember to do your job and
I don't want people to think just
because I'm a girl they have to stop
doing that well I think it's always been
about the team I want to make sure these
kids understand that you know I mean not
one person can carry the team in a game
situation no matter how bad or good I'm
doing they've stuck it out with me I
love how we can look at each other as
actual brothers and sisters we're all
like close to each other we don't really
bring anyone down
I really feel like they're my second
family that's just how it seems should
always be my first game I just went in
for a couple plays and I got hit it's
not too bad like I can handle this that
person went fine
all the other plates are fine and then
after that it just started building up
confident that I needed that's when they
put me as starting like for the JV team
I was completing my passes I was making
the right read for the most part and she
came back one day and she said my coach
wants to talk to you this was he said
like you know mr. Buchanan he said you
know your daughter has something that I
don't think anybody even understands yet
I want her to come on the varsity
football team for me it really doesn't
matter I think if you have a passion to
want to do something then good for you
more so fewer female playing playing a
male dominant sport right she took the
field
everybody erupted and you know few plays
later she made history history was made
as McKinley's Alexandria Buchanan became
the first ever female to start at
quarterback in Hawaii a varsity football
game tossing the first female touchdown
every Deeds up
that prompted a landslide of national
recognition the game-changer in every
sense fighters it was a really close
game as well we lost by one point and
that was the first time we've lost by
that little in years so everyone's
already excited about that following
Monday it was insane like everyone just
coming up to us congratulating us my
phone is blowing up with like messages
and stuff from people that I don't even
know that really pushed me because I saw
like people are noticing what I'm doing
so I have to play not only for myself
but for my team cuz they're counting on
me as well Alex made high school
football history but let's be real
nobody tries to go viral sometimes you
just make history cuz you're you I never
saw it as a big deal I see so many
quarterbacks on this island doing that
over and over and over and over and I
just feel bad because they're putting in
the work my boys are putting in the work
of my team and they are not getting all
of this attention as well all the
pressure does get to me sometimes I'd
say I had a lot more challenges this
year than last year not only is it my
second year playing for the varsity
level but I'm also getting all of this
attention people notice me now she's
been struggling since our first game
things have gotten tough
and I know it hasn't been easy for them
she's throwing the number of pics
returned for touchdowns the other way
anytime you're not doing well and you
know it's interesting how people will
jump off the bandwagon yeah there's a
lot of talking but you just let that go
through please focus on us if someone's
like hating on me or whatever saying
like you don't deserve this you don't
deserve that attention and stuff like I
sort of agree with them so I don't
really take it to heart which helps you
know yeah
I figure Alex and the team could use
some home field advantage since the LA
Clippers were in town my extra bias
Harris and one of the only female
coaches in the NBA
Natalie nakhon say to stop by and show
some love next game Friday
seriously inspiration thank ya I'm
trying to I'm learning from you so
whatever you do out there I'm just gonna
visualize it these guys nice to you
they're respectful yeah if you have a
problem what I'm not around I really
hope that they don't think anything
negative they could just be putting up a
front I guess but I really genuinely
think they have faith in me and they
trust me
on the field I'm supposed to say what
you're doing right - what you're doing
wrong and I expect them to do the same
for me I'm not just trying to boss them
around
Alexandria Buchanan is a real
quarterback but this girl's calling all
the shots she's not asking for your
permission
[Applause]
they knew was gonna be a play option
play cuz that's what we usually run on a
two-point conversion one of the guys
read it early and he caught up to me and
just sacked me there was nothing I could
do about it I got up and I thought I was
fine
[Music]
my coach goes to touch me like the job
and I like flinch like really badly and
he's like oh it's your shoulder hairs
like yeah I was out for the rest of the
game I couldn't do anything to help them
I felt bad because I felt like I let
them down they were counting on me I'm
the starting quarterback I should be
there like I'm the one getting all these
reps and working on these plays just so
I can help them do their jobs in that
moment especially I felt like I let them
down and it was hard for me I let my
voice down
broken clavicle so going to the hospital
fish but she wants to watch the rest
again how she is I'm definitely coming
back next season I don't know how my
parents feel about it yet but I will
definitely be back hopefully stronger
and better than ever to show everybody
what a girl can do I have learned so
much and I've got to meet so many great
people because of it I wouldn't change
this opportunity for the world
drew Brees couldn't make it to Hawaii he
was busy breaking records of his own so
I called in a favor because everyone
deserves the biggest fan
hey this is Drew Brees with the New
Orleans good how you feeling I see
you've got the sling on yeah I broke my
collarbone oh no or just in this past
game yeah this past one I can tell you
this I've had I've had five surgeries in
my life and all of them were from
football sometimes that happens right
but you will come back stronger than
ever I was so pumped to hear about your
story thank you so much well let's talk
X's and O's do you like being under
center with the play-action and throwing
a deep or I like shotgun if it's like a
shorter path I like play-action though
okay so you hand the ball off you run
option and then you'll do play-action
off yeah yeah hopefully good for you
guys I think that you've accomplished
thus far and just know that you're gonna
come back stronger from this injury all
right Alexandria great talking to you
talking we're gonna talk again okay bye
bye
[Music]
it's so cool I never thought I'd be able
to like talk to them I've been watching
it what ever since I was like really
really little so this is kind of like
it's really unreal you know like you
never think like not at school and the
middle it was good they you know they
just gonna FaceTime do break it is one
day I poked my collar boots up for the
Maci I was a really good flight football
player that I played tackle and when
they hit me I said I don't I'm gonna go
put basketball I thought it was safer a
sock with Natalie yesterday and she said
if we have the opportunity to inspire
other people not wanna be in our
position then we definitely should
this is Carmelo Anthony thanks for
watching to meet more heroes go to be
real da bleacherreport.com